this is a study that says smoking weed
age your brain by almost three years
pretty believable I mean did everyone
think that's super healthy three years
off for an entire life the rescuers the
researchers analyzed 60,000 brain scans
hmm 30 1227 people and they're saying
that weed ages your brain by 3 years
yeah well 3 defined as reduced blood
flow through the organ but they no link
was found between depression and brain
aging result stress bipolar disorder a
cellar it's brain aging by one point six
years hmm well they said alcohol is by
0.6 years I think [ __ ] so I'll call that
marijuana's way worse yeah yeah see
boozing was also shown to age organ by
0.6 years well last three years there
really matter so you guys still smoke
not really very rarely I used to go
asleep but then you know I gotta be you
know like my son moves with cries or
something like that so I didn't want to
be in that deep of asleep and I heard
from that sleep doctor Rogen's that it's
not good sleep when that's why I sought
to you I stopped doing it once I heard
him he goes alcohol or marijuana you
guys think it's helped me go to sleep
you're not getting great sleep yeah so
even though you have dreams I thought
that was the main thing as long as it's
REM do you have a good sleep they said
no there's like stages to getting there
yes you're skipping I already need it
anyways Six Flags
yeah I'm trying to get more positive
light here maybe well how was that was
that pain or is that fun I love it I
want to go back I love that stuff but I
get sick do you get sick on
rollercoasters
I do get sick I'm wrong you're sick now
I guess I did it before Santa Monica
Pier
I get sick like a pair on the [ __ ]
that [ __ ] they have that thing they have
this thing all the rock frog can't do
circles or rock oh no I get sick I'm
like mmm have you always been that way I
feel like it's an older now because like
as a kid I could go on non-stop and
couldn't get enough as a kid and now
when I do this [ __ ] I want to do I get
sick from that I get sick from man I get
sick from like if I eat shitty now
you're real sick but you lost sugar
somebody's like now you throw up it's a
real shame
that's so much fun at those parks men
yeah I'd rather go there than Disneyland
as a grown man because it's like all the
legit rollercoasters where it really
where as Six Flags Santa Ana Clarita no
I never let's yeah you can drive by and
only took me 40 minutes to get there 40
minutes do they have the serious
rollercoasters some of the best in the
world
really no one was there I don't know
what was going in scary hell yeah it is
right
I've thrown the chin on below the belt I
can't though the amount of confidence we
put into the workers and the beams and
all that stuff now like would you have
her bungee jump in Mexico I sure would
never would I sure would I see some
credentials where credential did you get
I'm sorry what call what what degree in
engineering did you get to apply all
this stuff to this beam here well on
this dodgy wooden ramp I'm gonna jump
off of
when I went parachuting once and the
gentleman folding my chute up he's
folding the chute up and he smelled a
little bit like booze I'll never forget
it I was like I don't know man now
depends on your folding this chute now
what is that influence yeah and also
like is there a specific way obviously
and if you get a fold wrong okay well am
I gonna yeah it's amazing the most spare
shoes we just assume everything's all
good the amount of confidence we put in
flight you know pilots and [ __ ]
people at Six Flags in general it works
somehow because when you assume you're
lifeguards a badass when you swim in
those ocean waters well so so that's why
corruption is really really bad because
like in Turkey there was an earthquake I
think it was in 1993 or something and a
lot of people were killed in Turkey like
crazy amount and one of the reasons they
were killed was because the building
inspectors would be bought off so is not
was shitty cement with air in it well
when you do that you [ __ ] your your
building collapses in an earthquake so
when you have incorruptible institutions
like in California do you know they
inspect the [ __ ] out of those buildings
and it's a pain in the ass and all that
for this time he's a journalist who have
meshes himself in the world and actually
goes through it and it's [ __ ] that
looks like Elon Musk
and after yeah he like really bad look
I've never seen you on before hit the
lottery I sound like an old video and
he's in like a dude Elon Musk is one of
those guys
Elon Musk you get him on the podcast
right now go up go up the third picture
with PayPal look at that that's Elon on
the right no yeah what happened bro
money the top right number the top right
[Music]
millions bro Oh
Heath look good his hair looks good he
dresses good I love it he looks like
he's in a movie right there yeah I'm in
a movie what movie you shooting Ilan you
sexy [ __ ] ease in a courtroom winning
money it's cool that PayPal pictures
there's a nerd go to that Tesla jacket
less one second Tony Hawk eclipses
second picture this guy yeah look at
that Tessa look at my [ __ ] jackets my
company she looks cool what you gonna
ask me some questions I'm in my
warehouse of the company that I own my
wife has a real thing for him all those
do you know how many women I know that
say that that's the guy is that my wife
is unabashedly in love go down can we
scroll down to some other photos see
what else we got my team I hit him on
the phone they're going that to it they
were going that that yeah hello he was
dating a rich old girl
Amber Heard and then they broke up right
something happened something bad
happened right did something bad happen
did you couldn't get out the door cuz
all the money I was just kicking like
bad she like was sick you dated this
girl she was dating her now oh wow
that's Tuesday my partition
what's her name I forgot well why is she
famous she is now cuz he's like here's a
bill yes I wonder if he does like the
Jeter thing you know when Jeter like
foxing gives you like a gift bag with a
baseball in it I wonder if he gives you
like a test selfies I get the [ __ ] out
of here kid hula and here's a USB but
what if you saw the girl that used to
[ __ ] get the but get the best I said
like the PD 100 and then you got the
three then you know the $50,000 one I
know that'd be sad he's like yes
I know one of those radar dragon lady's
man's ladies man one of the greatest
most brilliant comedians of all times
and they got you they got me
they've got me but I'm gonna learn from
them and I'm gonna pull it up and we're
gonna get you on there is it gay I would
love to let me be honest I'm so happy
for you John you might have heard that
new you know who told me D'Elia Chris
D'Elia if you guys don't know who yes he
does
he's like a podcast he's a podcast guy
yeah pockets yeah and he he said did you
hear about Kalin and my initial thought
this is your sabe he died
no no not death he's young and he's in
[ __ ] he said did you hear about about
Kalin and I said I knew it because the
first time I met Kalin nice always nice
but like FM FM inant and I thought he is
gay I know and I thought this was a come
out party and I got excited I said we're
gonna become a party for about time it's
about Jack it's about time he's been to
Brendan put him up to this did you shut
that hashtag it's about time there's a
whole thing of r.i.p Kalin as I know
it's people were sending it yeah I never
I never but I'm writing in my life well
we know because you thought Chris Brown
didn't beat Rihanna five years ago I
know you don't know Liz yeah I know I
know I don't I don't I was genuinely
happy when Chris told me about it
because I thought that's that is a
wonderful what a wonderful thing it's
hard for people in our business that are
talented to get stuff let's be honest a
lot of people get stuff and you're like
I cannot believe this is happening I'm
not gonna get mad I don't get mad at
anymore I just can't believe they're not
finding the best people for things
sometimes where you go how is that the
best shot how did you guys not I don't
know
so business I'm happy I'm happy for you
thanks pal and if if if if if if I feel
like it I will do I will do a couple
episode no I don't know and it'll say
it'll be scenes with Brian and I'll go
can I be with Tim no you gave me a
comment now you're being shitty shitty I
don't want to work with you I'd rather
work with Tim now get on you I have some
surprises up my sleeve back to Chicago a
lot I [ __ ] love it oh yeah man my I
was just saying the other day how much I
miss it I get I get in I get in these
mood to twice a year
in the dog days of summer which is right
now and right before Christmas I'm like
I can't live here anymore I gotta go
back to Chicago in the winters I don't
care if they don't even care don't I
don't even care you know why cuz you get
around each other and you eat food and
you drink and you hang out this whole
like XYZ is bad in the winter no one
cares they're they [ __ ] about it but we
really are like it gives us an
opportunity to sit in a room together
down in LA City you don't sit in a room
with anybody unless you're doing a
podcast or a meeting yeah yeah when's
the last time you just like hey come
over we'll all sit together and hang out
or have a dinner I hear you your family
care about those people to do that you
don't love your family that's a full
when someone's like you love your kids
or your wife it's like no yeah it's not
it's not like I went out of my way to be
like I really want to hang with these
people I have to yeah yeah literally
friends like you write like a group of
people that we meet with nothing doesn't
exist like my friends in Chicago I get
jealous they have friends that they see
after work is too busy busy yeah oh I
got a you know what I can come for 20 I
have a lunch I gotta go to a thing
that's it everybody everybody here is on
their way somewhere they don't have time
to stop yeah yeah this is a transient
city moving yeah it's the one my one
gripe about Los Angeles zero community
nobody gets together and has like you
know do you know your neighbors I
actually do only because if you if you
didn't have to do when you didn't have
kids
drivers correct sir you are coming out
children you don't know anyone who are
you raised by [ __ ] werewolf yeah I
know my neighbors when I was single I
know my neighbors now yeah gave real
well but you know them well I really
well enough as made with neighbors first
and last name the name is large Indian
family that's how you refer to these
people that is offensive that is so rude
in this climate it's a large Indian is
you a large Indian friends Dan Rome his
name is Daniel I made that name up Danny
Danny Danny
today in the India they're moving out
next week now